depends from what you think is a luxury
designed for me and all the Italian
design factories phenomenon is a new and
very contemporary form of art and poetry
then is art and poetry luxury I leave to
you the question
well it depends very much from the era
where we were working in for example in
my personal job in my work I am dealing
with the objects that are hundreds of
years old
if not a millinery solder if you think
how old is a bowl of a cup of a pot
thousand years old that means that
almost all the functional matters have
been have foundered a solution and the
space which is left is a still space
related to the emotions not so much to
the function you cannot invent so much
in my field
there are two two schools of thinking in
that one school says that okay in design
history there were periods of very very
tough economic and social situation like
if you take Finland no other new hope in
the thirties when FINA started to be in
an independent country and it was the
same period when it gave birth to the
best of its design the period of Alvar
Aalto just to quote one name to mention
one name or in if you think to italy
right after the war when italy was all
destroyed and the phenomenon during the
early 50s this phenomenon of the Italian
design factories started operating but
on the other hand there is the other
school that says the more we can afford
to experiment also look into the market
the more the wider and the healthier is
the market the better it is for
experiments experimental activities
we put more attention to the prices that
is evident self-evident but this is the
only modification for the rest since I
do not believe design is a luxury but
design is a new form of art and poetry
so people needs art and poetry as well
they will need a design so I am trying
to continue to devil the best possible
design I will buy sure not decrease the
effort to produce the best possible
design that is sure
between having a design with a lot of
integrity and so also being accepted by
the market an American designer I'm on
live in the thirties was was a saying
was a was practicing the strategy
invented by him that was called the
Meyer strategy meaning most advanced yet
acceptable by by the people this is the
factor what makes a good design to be
together able to bring to be able to
bring together the best possible quality
in terms of expression in artistic terms
and that is a cultural matter and also
to be understood by final customers and
that is a commercial matter the change
of design is that we try to put these
two apparently opposite facts of matters
together
being a research lab I am allowed to
take by definition to take more risk in
my activity and to work more close to
the border line the border line which
divides the era of possible from the era
of not possible okay the difference with
the mass production company is that the
mass production company they try to work
as far as possible from the burden line
instead being an Italian design company
my role and my destiny is to work as
close as possible to the border line by
definition I am asked to take more risk
in my industrial activity what is more
exciting goes
going back to this example of Richard
Sutter water cathode this was a good
example because Richard wanted to have
Polly sensorial multi-sensorial object I
mean the knobs are not appealing only to
the see seeing of touching but also to
other senses for example hearing he
wanted to produce a melody not only that
he wanted a melody remembering when he
was a child living in Germany in a
village with a river and under even was
passing by a steamboat he wanted his
cattle producing the same melody after
like one and a half year my technicians
were not able to find a way so it was a
bloody to put the project on the side
and to abandon it until then two years
later one of Sutter sisters living in
Germany found out in the Black Forest a
smaller craftsmen producing a chorused
chorused are these a pipes that you put
inside and that are producing the melody
so after some negotiation we had a
special production of two different
versions of pipes with me and with the
sea which allowed me to start again with
the project we done was a present in 82
and became one of the most important
élisa élisa product
going back to this example of witches up
water cathode this was a good example
because Richard wanted to have a Polly
sensorial multi-sensorial object I mean
the knobs are not appealing only to the
see seeing or touching but also to other
senses for example hearing he wanted to
produce a melody not only that he wanted
a melody remembering when he was a child
living in Germany in a village with a
river and on the river was passing by a
steamboat
he wanted his cattle producing the same
melody after like one and a half year my
technicians were not able to find a way
so I was a bloody to put the project on
the side and to abandon it
until then two years later one of supper
sisters living in Germany found out in
the Black Forest a smaller craftsman
producing a chorus chorus are these a
pipes that you put inside and that are
producing the melody so after some
negotiation we had a special production
of two different versions of pipes with
me and with the sea which allowed me to
start again with the project we done was
a present in 82 and became one of the
most important élisa élisa product
I think that our identity as an Italian
design factory of a research laboratory
into the field of design stays precisely
in that we are able to express different
localities of different local cultures
represented by our designers because if
we work with Philip stark he is
representing and people is looking into
within his projects to look expecting to
find an expression of French culture if
we are working with Michael Graves
people the quality of his work stays in
the fact that his work is coming out
from American cultures or if with
Japanese or Brazilian or British and the
characteristic of a preserving this
locality these local cultures is a big
strength that is one of the skills of
the Italian design factories not global
at all in a way we become interesting on
a global of scenario right because we
represent the very specific local
cultures which are represented by our
designers
as far as I can see this is a phenomenon
of the Italian design factors which is
which is today the kind of kind of hair
of all the phenomenon like the deutsche
werkbund of the Bauhaus the we never
stated the arts and crafts in England
and so on is continuing to to to act
well in terms of where the creative
energies can come from I agree that
today in this moment Italy has a little
freshness like we had many years ago and
there are counter which are apparently
in this moment more interesting for
example you UK Japan even probably us at
least and into the world of architecture
if not of design and so we are very much
looking to this area